welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange is officially
joining spider-man in the upcoming
spider-man 3 a far from home follow-up
that
is blowing open the live-action
spider-verse with jamie foxx elektro
and reportedly others from past fighty
films and with dr strange's sequel
multiverse of madness being directed by
original tobey maguire spider-man
director sam rainey
the sorcerer supreme steven strange
confirmed as tom holland peter parker's
guide through the multiverse is really
the final piece of this puzzle solving
how all of this madness will work
essentially last week sony gave us some
multiverse plot holes but this week
doctor strange revealed those holes to
be
sparkle portals and we as the america's
ass facing oblivion
are grateful for the backup
thank you is that everyone what you
wanted more hell yeah we want more
we will not rest until peter says norman
osborne three times into a mirror and
then willem devoe pops up
avenge me that's the avenger we deserve
let us break down the huge implications
of this news
and the wild plot this spider-man doctor
strange team-up will probably have
spoiler warning in case i'm right okay
doctor strange joining tom holland peter
parker isn't just the elder mentor mcu
team up that tony stark was in
spider-man homecoming or nick fury was
in spider-man far from home hell even
those were more game-changing than we
thought they were going to be going into
them iron man ended homecoming by
unveiling the iron spider armor that
would enable peter to join the fight in
infinity war in an end game
fury ended far from home by revealing
himself as a freaking scroll
shapeshifter with his real self playing
hide the slipper with more scrolls in
space
i believe setting up the fury series or
a future secret invasion plot
doctor strange will continue that
mentorship evolution which if you've
been watching closely has already been
discreetly set up in past films peter
met doctor strange and infinity war
aboard ebony maw's q-ship
wha what is he your ward no i'm peter by
the way
doctor strange oh you're using their
made up names um
i'm spider-man then but then peter
returned an endgame and he rambled to
tony stark about a conversation he and
dr strange had
do you remember when we were in space
and i got all dusty and i must have
passed out because i woke up and you
were gone
but dr strange was there right and he
was like it's been five years come on
they need us
and then he started doing the yellow
sparkly thing that he does all the time
what are you doing
oh this is nice and in this moment i
think tony recognized peter moving
on to a point in his understanding of
the universe in which he no longer needs
iron man
the smartass who once called peter
tony's ward is now
a more apt guide to help this kid
navigate a fractured reality
and looking ahead to their partnership
there was one overlooked moment in far
from home that we have to revisit
there are multiple realities peter this
is earth dimension 616. i'm from earth
833.
i'm sorry you're saying there's a
multiverse because i thought that was
just theoretical i mean that completely
changes how we understand the initial
singularity we're talking about
an internal inflation system and how
does that even work with all the quantum
consensus now of course mysterio was
full of it he wasn't a warrior from
another universe he was just a bitter
ex-stark employee exploiting a nerd's
imagination about quantum mechanics and
alternate realities
the story you created of a soldier from
another earth named quentin fighting
space monsters in europe
is totally ridiculous and apparently
exactly the kind of thing people will
believe right now
i mean everybody bought it but as marvel
head kevin feige himself confirmed that
does not mean the multiverse doesn't
exist still
just because quentin beck makes up lies
about the multiverse
doesn't mean it isn't real and peter's
nerdy multiverse fascination remains
and there was one crucial line from the
ancient one during dr strange's
inaugural trip through the multiverse
that i think
is gonna be very important to his
stewardship of this particular nerd
is only one of an infinite number
worlds without end who are you
in this vast multiverse but to explain
why peter will need a multiverse hopper
like doctor strange in his next film
when at the time his main concern at the
end of heart from home seemed to be
clearing his name from mysterio's
attempt to frame him with j jonah
jameson's doctor news footage
we have to look at how marvel's
interweaving narratives for
phase four will link together and how
each of these titles will change the
game in their own unique way
i will admit that in order to make these
connections i do have to spend a lot of
time watching movies and tv for work but
i often
don't have time to read books anymore i
miss reading books but thankfully i am
back in the book game with the sponsor
of this video
blinkist so blinkist gives you the best
key takeaways from over 3
000 nonfiction bestsellers condensed
down into 15 minute
blinks which you can read or listen to
on your phone your tablet or your web
browser
see here on the app homepage i can see
all the links that are for me that are
recommended things like the checklist
manifesto the gift of failure they also
have some recommended audio books like
super immunity change by design sun
tzu's the art of war
which i have been applying to defeat
tommy blinkist also offers its members
exclusive original content from top
authors and creative thinkers and
full-length audiobooks at a great
discount for premium subscribers
over 14 million people use blinkist to
deepen their knowledge and topics like
self-improvement
mindfulness parenting happiness and more
i could bang out one or two whole books
on blinkist in the time it takes me to
make dinner or run an errand they've
also got some real bangers on there
including deep thinking by gary kasparov
or a brief history of time by stephen
hawking
which is even briefer when you consider
it via blinkist the first 100 people to
go to blinkist.com
new rockstars are going to get unlimited
access for one week to try it out you'll
also get 25
off if you want the full membership that
seven day trial is completely free and
you can cancel at any time so
check out blinkist at blinkist.com new
rockstars so spider-man 3 is
increasingly looking like a live
action spider-verse story with jamie
foxx electro last seen in a separate
film universe jk simmons j jonah jameson
also from an additionally separate film
universe
marvel's multiverse master joining this
story and yeah past spider-man director
sam rainey directing doctor strange in
the multiverse madness coming just a few
months after spider-man 3.
all of this evidence seems to confirm
what fans have been hoping for
a live-action version of the widely
successful spider-man into the
spider-verse that adapts the web of life
and destiny from the spider-verse comics
in a way that reconciles the good and
the bad from past spider-man films that
brings back toby mcguire brings back
andrew garfield
and hopefully leaves this universe with
a live-action miles morales and a
live-action gwen stacy but how do we get
to there
from here well let's look at marvel's
now first official phase four title
one division based on the recent trailer
for this disney plus series coming
before the end of 2020 it appears as
though wanda maximoff is contained
in a pocket reality that her chaos magic
allows her to warp she is being
monitored externally by sword sentient
world observation and response
department and there is some evidence
that she is being manipulated
internally by evil forces like the witch
agatha
and marvel's devil mephisto famously in
the house of m comics
wanda maximov warps all of reality in
the marvel world into alternate
universes that may be what we're seeing
here in wandavision with sword
trying to confine that reality warp into
a small town but wanda's chaos magic
could burst out of that bubble maybe
thanks to those evil entities
and flood the entire known universe and
while a universal reset
could seem like an insane level of power
for a scarlet witch who previously was
just doing like hand dances
kevin feige did confirm that scarlet
witch is the most powerful character now
in the mcu
as of endgame in your opinion who would
be the strongest
marvel hero if you if you look at
endgame wanda maximoff was going to kill
thanos
if he hadn't desperately that's as
scared as i've ever seen thanos
and if he hadn't said decimate my entire
team to get her off of me
i think she would have done it in the
comics one is mutant abilities stemmed
from her being cursed by the demon
chauthon as a baby
canonically in the mcu her powers
derived from the mind stone via hydra's
experiments with loki's scepter
the mind stone if you remember was the
final infinity stone thanos plugged into
his gauntlet it allowed him to
simultaneously link with all minds in
the universe so that he could dust half
of them perhaps one division will
compound these backstories
wanda cursed with dormant magic by a
demon as a baby but that magic was
unlocked for her to use by the mind
stone as a young adult and now in one
division vision is back mind stoned back
in his head
at least in this projected reality and
maybe that stone's return is
evidence of wanda's ongoing mind
stone-derived powers
which allow her to warp all of reality
beyond the small town
when she has a psyonic meltdown
triggered not just by losing vision but
by losing the
illusion of her children that would set
up a marvel phase four in which the
entire mcu is shattered into various
else worlds in one elseworld reality we
see a black widow's spy drama with
galena beloved that could end with
natasha on a different path than the one
that ended with her dead and end game
another elseworld
shanxi where super powered individuals
fight in tournaments for the ten rings
in another else world
eternals resetting reality with an
ancient history that establishes mutant
kind
as a normal part of this world all of
these alternate timelines could be the
backdrop of loki on disney plus
scheduled to come out early to mid 2021
that is confirmed to feature the tva
time variance authority marvel's
timeline enforcement agency that polices
the broken timelines
and those who break them so if you have
trouble keeping all the broken universe
shards straight don't worry i'm sure
time cop owen wilson will
chow it down on a hollow screen or
something are you kidding me of course
why not
but really all of this madness will boil
over it sounds like in spider-man 3.
of all of the marvel heroes that i've
been talking about spider-man has the
richest comic history webbing together
various alternate spider-verses via what
it's called the web of light and destiny
it's an interdimensional nexus that
bridges together peter parker's earth
616
miles morales earth 1610 when stacy's
earth 65
et cetera et cetera et cetera so perhaps
spider-man 3 opens with peter parker
having to give up being spider-man since
the public turned on him after mysterio
getting visited from
doctor strange through a sparkle portal
could get shut up for a second just come
with me and then doctor strange flies
peter through the multiverse a
shimmering
web with each section within those web
strands containing a glimpse into an
alternate reality kind of like the
moments in time reflected in the
interstellar tesseract maybe one moment
shows toby maguire peter parker fighting
doc ock on the train maybe another
moment shows animated miles morales
fighting kingpin
and during this strange repeats to peter
the words the ancient one told him when
she opened his third eye
your universe is only one of an infinite
number worlds without
end who are you in this vast multiverse
but this time doctor strange is telling
them this because
he needs peter to understand that he is
not the only
spider-man that peter parker shares that
title with an
endless array of doppelgangers and
counterparts including
tobey maguire andrew garfield miles
morales gwen stacy miguel o'hara
spider uk billy braddock strange needs
his universe of spider-man to face an
inter-dimensional crisis a band of
villains hailing from different
universes
hijacking the fractured reality post-war
division coming together as
the sinister six their goal to eliminate
each
of the spider-mans from each of their
own respective
universes i mean you know it's gonna
piss off toby maguire peter parker when
danger invades his world from a broken
doorway
you'll get your rent when you fix this
damn door i mean the elements of the
toby maguire spider-man films have to be
important because again
sam raimi himself is directing the
immediate next part
of doctor strange's battle that this
spider-man movie is now looking like the
first act two
raymie even called this shot 16 years
ago doctor strange that's pretty good
but it's taken how did he know i mean
seriously this is looking like a crazy
crossover spider-man 3 could be
the infinity war cliffhanger to dr
strange to the multiverse of madness as
the endgame resolution and with scarlet
witch confirmed to return in multiverse
madness and is now
even more likely that she will be the
multiverse villain that doctor strange
has to find and
save so that she can wake up from her
nightmare and use her chaos magic to
collapse the multiverse of madness
into one stable combined universe going
forward
look folks doctor strange and spider-man
are going to team up in some way to face
a multiverse based threat that will
involve
past alt universe villains like jamie
foxx electro
this is fact it is confirmed so to me
this
is the way forward that i think makes
the most sense based on everything else
we know about the current state of the
mcu
even if jamie foxx plays a new version
of elektro the classic green and yellow
suited one instead of his dr manhattan
look as is being reported why would they
go to the trouble of casting jamie foxx
why not cast someone new and probably
less expensive this connection to the
andrew garfield universe is
obviously crucial to whatever story they
have planned yes
it is confusing it's a mysterious move
but bringing in multiverse pioneer dr
steven strange is the
clearest imaginable answer to that
mystery and i am kind of thinking a
title like spider-man
home world would be interesting but that
rumored spider-man home six does still
kind of work i'm curious to hear your
title pitches
you can also discuss these theories with
me on rockstar's official discord server
by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars subscribe to new
rockstars hit that notification bell
follow me on instagram
eavos follow new rockstars thank you for
watching and uh you know what let's drop
that home conceit from the title and
just
title it this spiderman
[Music]
you